today on the matt welsh show a prominent
psychologist suggests that white people
should kill themselves while another
worries that white people are haunted by
the ghosts of whiteness it's just more
radical leftism for mental health
professionals the entire industry is
rife with it we'll talk about the
consequences of that fact today also dr
fauci endorses vaccine mandates for
children and makes a predictably
misleading argument in favor of them a
security guard shoots a man because he
wasn't wearing a mask and says it's
self-defense hollywood turns out another
rope remake and speaking of hollywood
why was james corden stopping traffic
and thrusting his pelvis in the faces of
motorists we'll try to answer that
question and many more today on the matt
walsh
[Music]
show you know one thing that's uh very
difficult these days is to find
companies that share our values um as we
uh
as i always talk about you know in in
this culture today with all of our
institutions being overrun by leftism
especially the corporate institutions
it's really hard to find companies that
share values and then you're giving your
money to people who hate you so they can
go and spread messages that you oppose
and that's why you need charity mobile
charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company uh with charity mobile you can
join a company that shares your beliefs
and they're not going to cancel or
censor you for them far from it in fact
they're going to take a five percent of
your monthly plan price and they're
going to give it to the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice so they
are working with you in the culture
charity mobile makes it easy to switch
you can keep your existing phone number
and you may even be able to keep your
existing phone on top of it excellent
coverage with nationwide service on
america's most reliable network
and also of course 5g phones are
available as well new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation and free shipping
when you mention offer code walsh so
make sure you do that now switch to
charity mobile and support a company and
causes that you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention the
offer code walsh
well the american association of
psychoanalysis and clinical social work
is an organization that you've never
heard of and you shouldn't need to ever
hear of it it's one of the many
associations and organizations for
people in the psychology or psychiatry
or therapy fields the psycho industry as
i call it not so lovingly you might
think that the things these people talk
about when they gather for their
seminars and so forth would be little
interest to you just sort of dry and
academic and only relevant to the
members of those professions but as it
turns out the things they talk about
with each other do have a profound
impact on the rest of us for example i'm
reading a book now called saving normal
by alan francis who's a psychiatrist and
one of the guys prominently involved in
the discussions and meetings that
eventually led to the release of the
fourth edition of the diagnostic and
statistical manual or dsm-4 those
conversations really mattered a lot to
the rest of us even if we weren't privy
to them because as francis argues in his
book the dsm especially the next and
most recent edition dsm-5
is a travesty which helped to create a
situation where now any and all human
emotions and behaviors can be
categorized as sort of manifestations of
mental illness
now the american association for
psychoanalysis and clinical social work
isn't involved in producing anything
like the dsm but this group and its
members
do have some ideas about what sorts of
behaviors and ideas should be considered
disordered and how they should be
treated so that to that end the the
organization held a seminar recently one
in a series of seminars titled nice
white therapists deconstructing
whiteness towards an anti-racist
clinical practice on their website they
explained that the intention is to
devote 2021 to a study of whiteness
through a series of seminars and small
group encounters our conversation
leaders will help us excavate white
identity we will explore our denial
disavow disassociation and even pleasure
in the searing traumas of slavery and
violence that built this country and
form all of our identities as people who
are not black
not black that's our identity as white
people we're defining the negative now
as not black the speakers have all made
the negative connotation extremely clear
if it wasn't already clinical
psychologist natasha stovall kicked
things off back in march by rambling
about how the ghost of whiteness
might zap us of our psychic energy this
is all very scientific you see listen to
this
you know whiteness is like something
that white clients are
you know really
split off from often
and that it comes back as a ghost
and kind of interferes with
psychotherapeutic work interferes with
symbolization with mourning um and then
this disavowal
from the identification of whiteness
create you know leads to a creation of
the self
that
you know cuts one off from like
empathetic identification from people
um who have a different who are
different in some way and also and then
at the same time drains off you know
sort of the psychic energy
of the person
of the white person and i think that
that's like an incredibly valuable
conceptualization that i think
immediately kind of
you know kind of encapsulates something
that can be very useful as a way of
thinking about the things that you see
with white clients including like these
very typical presentations in private
practice anxiety depression uh social
isolation isolation within relationships
like these things i think are often
you know you can be depending on the
situation can be conceived as
not just about whiteness but not helped
by whiteness you know exacerbated by
whiteness
you know she sounds more like a racist
miss cleo than a medical professional
and and she wasn't done she also claimed
that whiteness is hostile violent
destructive and annihilating there seem
to be some redundancy going on there
violent and hostile as opposed to
violent but not hostile i don't know
but that's really the least of our
worries here listen to this a really
important piece of working with white
clients is to keep in mind that you know
like that
when racism or when whiteness is
deployed against people who aren't white
it's
hostile it is violent it is
um
you know it's destructive it is
annihilating
and that that's a piece of whiteness
that we really need to like reconnect
with
like that is something that we need to
always be mindful of as white people and
white therapists that like what we see
in ourselves in other white people and
from white patients is not the same
thing that's seen by people who are on
the other end of whiteness
not to be outdone the most recent talk
in this series was with a professor of
psychology at duquesne university named
derek hook professor hook actually
defended the idea that white people
should commit mass suicide as a quote
ethical act
no big deal here just a guy who teaches
psychology actually advocating for
suicide and advocating for it on a
racial basis
no less here he is listen to this
he made the assertion that white people
should commit suicide as an ethical act
and here's a quote from him directly the
reality in south africa today is that
most white people spend their whole
lives only engaging black south africans
in subservient positions
my question is then how can a person not
be racist if that's the way they live
their lives the only way then for white
people to become part of africa is not
to exist as white people anymore if the
goal is to dismantle white supremacy and
white supremacy is white culture then
the goal has to be it has to be to
dismantle white culture and ultimately
white people themselves the total
integration into africa by white people
will also automatically then mean the
death of white people as white as a
concept would not exist
anymore so here's the kind of crazy
gambit um of this talk i want to suggest
that psychoanalytically we could even
make the argument that there was
something ethical in delphi's statements
now i suppose you know parenthetically
we could say that del paul's kind of a
young fired up academic and maybe you
know there's a little bit uh too much of
a dramatization in some of his his
comments but nevertheless i want to make
the argument that there is some kind of
ethical dimension to his his
provocations
um i think that del paul took his white
audience to the threshold of a type of
symbolic extinction or at least the
contemplation of what that might be he
took them to a proposed end of whiteness
or in more psych analytic terms we could
say that del port offered his white
audience the opportunity one they didn't
seem to appreciate for the most part but
the opportunity to contemplate what we
could call the castration
of
of whiteness
of course the most immediate response to
professor hook might be you know you
first chief you're whiter than a jar of
mayonnaise buried under a foot of snow
if you think white people should commit
suicide well why haven't you led by
example not that i want you to okay only
a malignant psychopath would want people
to kill themselves and unfortunately we
have malignant psychopaths teaching and
training the next generation of
psychologists in this country so that's
that's not what i would want to see
happen but that's what he says he wants
none of this comes as a surprise we know
that this the psycho industry is overrun
with steeped in down to its core far
left radicalism and this fact is most
profoundly demonstrated by the gender
issue
which we talk about all the time of
course most psychologists psychiatrists
therapists counselors and all of their
various organizations now affirm the
idea that a five-year-old boy might have
the essence of a girl trapped mystically
inside him or a 16 year old girl might
really be a boy yearning to escape her
female shell or she might she might not
be anything in particular which case our
mental health professionals will happily
refer her over to the plastic surgeons
where she can undergo non-binary surgery
which is a thing now to remove all
sexual indicators from her body or at
least the ones they can remove they
still can't remove her dna of course
though i'm sure they're working on that
problem
as we speak now the point is that what
you just heard there in those clips
is not an exception or an aberration
that was not a window into the fringes
that's mainstream that's what the mental
health experts believe this is what they
say this is what they tell their
patients
the exceptions and aberrations are on
the other side they are the normal ones
now we know that every institution in
our culture has been infiltrated by the
far left there's no reason why the
psycho industry should be any different
but the militant leftism among mental
health professionals is especially
dangerous and it's worth thinking about
because these people
those with the prefix psych on their job
title are in the business of identifying
diagnosing and treating sicknesses of
the mind
if somebody has a neurological condition
like dementia
they'll go to a neurologist so joe biden
you know he may also consult a
psychiatrist but dementia is a physical
disease of the physical brain and
therefore it's outside of the
psychiatrists or psychologists purview
no so they're concerned with mental
illnesses sicknesses of the mind in
other words they're concerned with
deciding how and what a person is
supposed to think and what sorts of
behaviors those thoughts are supposed to
produce
when it comes down to it they're really
dealing with human nature they decide
whether a mind
falls within the normal scope of human
nature or whether it falls outside of it
now i've explained before why i'm
frankly skeptical of the whole business
i'm not totally convinced that anyone
can diagnose the mind especially because
nobody can even say for sure what the
mind is and how it works and how it
exists and why
the idea that anyone can go to school
for a few years and then be in a
position to determine whether an
individual's mind is working properly or
not
is to me questionable that's not to say
that mental disorders don't exist or
that they can't be reliably identified
and treated it's simply to say that it's
a very tricky business it's trickier
than most people probably realize and so
tricky that would require an immense
amount of scientific discipline and
restraint
not to mention a deep wisdom and insight
to do correctly
but this industry has not operated with
discipline or restraint and certainly
not wisdom
it has instead run roughshod over the
human condition relegating thousands of
normal human behaviors and thought
processes to the mental illness bin
and it's acted politically and cowardly
changing its own positions not based on
science but on political pressure and
social trends
that's how a man who calls himself a
woman went from clinically speaking a
deluded mental patient to a hero
speaking his truth in the span of like
just a few years really
there was no science to support this
shift there was none there were only
politics and ideology and that's the
primary concern
of the mental health industry
and yet in spite of these issues people
still trust
these people to tell them about
themselves to decide what is normal and
what's not
what's healthy and what's not what is
natural and what's not what is true and
what's not
and the industry has used this power in
really insidious ways and the results
have been catastrophic
so what does that mean does it mean that
you shouldn't trust any psychiatrist or
psychologist or therapist no it just
means you should understand the context
you should understand that these people
are fruits
growing from a tree that is poisoned at
its roots
you can still find a good apple in there
but you have to you have to look and be
very careful
and then again you know i would say the
same for teachers i would say the same
for politicians
people in my line of work and media
caution and discernment is the way err
on the side of skepticism
because you have no choice
that's what it's like to live in a
collapsing civilization you cannot trust
the institutions
especially not the ones who have helped
to cause the collapse in the first place
now let's get to our five headlines
you know i'm traveling uh now i'm on the
road and that means unfortunately
planes
ubers cabs that kind of thing i gotta
deal with all of that and uh for me that
also means that motion sickness is part
of the bargain at least it was part of
the bargain until
i discovered relief ban relief ban is
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraine hangover morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more the
product is drug free and the best part i
think is that it's non-drowsy and there
are no side effects at all it's just
something that you wear and it solves a
problem for you this technology was
originally developed over 20 years ago
in hospitals to relieve nausea from
patients but now through relief band
it's available to the masses how it
works is relief band stimulates a nerve
in the wrist that travels to the part of
your brain that causes nausea and it
blocks that signal and that's a lot more
effective than just taking a you know a
pill or something like that that you
find at a gas station ensure that nausea
is never the reason to miss out on
life's important moments right now
relief ban has an exclusive offer
just for matt walsh listeners if you go
to reliefband.com and use promo code
walsh you'll receive 20 off plus free
shipping and a no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use our promo code walsh for
20 off
so um
joe biden
well we'll start with this you've
probably seen this this video by now but
we'll play it as well because we can't
we can't uh just gloss over it
joe biden was at the dignified transfer
of 13 troops killed in afghanistan at
dover air force base over the weekend
yes this was yesterday actually joe
biden had kind of a big weekend
because
before that he was
meeting in the white house with the
prime minister of israel and he he
appeared to nod off and start sleeping
in the middle of the meeting and the
fact checkers have jumped
to his to his uh to his aid and said no
he wasn't sleeping he was just i think
what they're saying now is he was
resting his eyes
while someone was talking to him he
started just kind of resting his eyes
for about for about 15 solid seconds he
wasn't falling asleep he was resting his
eyes
that doesn't make it much better you
know if the president united states
can't even sit and talk to a person
for a few minutes without having to rest
his eyes
so that happened on saturday
and then on sunday he was at the
dignified transfer as these troops were
killed in afghanistan tragically were
brought home
and um we'll play the clip here this is
from the fox news feed
and the the audio doesn't
isn't the point it's more what you see
so if you haven't seen this yet let's
play this and and see what you see see
if you can catch joe biden doing
anything that seems a little bit
inappropriate as you talked about
sergeant
nicole g who was the one of the two
female marines who were killed among the
13
she was the one who posted that
instagram post holding the baby saying i
love my
job just a few days ago
so he goes and he goes for the watch
check
very very quickly and then he realizes
what he did so he tries to play it off
like he was just adjusting his hands you
know
and he waited until he had his hand on
his heart and he waited till
they were bringing their hands down and
he could just sneak the look real quick
now
look if if this was with someone else
i might say that the criticism is unfair
and kind of tacky
i don't wear watches normally but when i
do uh i i often will check them just
sort of like reflexively not because i'm
bored or i want to leave wherever i am
it might be because of that but also
it's just kind of like you have it on so
you just sort of
it's a reflex in fact even though i
don't wear watches very often i'll
sometimes
look at my wrist as if i have one i'll
do that move
um
so you'd like to give joe biden the
benefit of the doubt and if it was
somebody else who has proven
their patriotism and their love for
country and their concern for other
human beings and you saw them doing that
then maybe you'd give them the benefit
of the doubt but um here i can't give
biden the benefit of the doubt because
of his general indifference and
callousness
not just him but everybody running the
country right now the whole ruling class
that's i think a big a big part of the
story that they they don't they don't
care that much
about americans
they don't care that much about the
lives that are lost
uh i would have said that even before
everything that's happened over the last
uh over the last couple of weeks but but
especially now i don't know how else to
explain what we've seen
where there are americans who are still
trapped in afghanistan and now have been
officially abandoned they're on their
own
apparently
the total lack of urgency
instead of having the attitude that
we're gonna find these people no matter
what it takes we're gonna get them all
home safe and alive no matter what we're
gonna get our people home all american
citizens
they just have this lackadaisical
attitude about it
which if you really care about americans
if you care about people in general you
wouldn't you wouldn't be able to help
but have a really urgent
attitude but that's not what they've had
so
because of that because of this
background on joe biden
i see that and i think well it is
exactly what it looks like
he can't be bothered he's been
inconvenienced
these 13 troops who um he got killed
their bloods on his hands
if you were a decent person you'd think
he he he would be there
weeping he would be overcome by
not only sadness for the families but
also personal guilt
thinking about what he just did
because he so badly botched this
evacuation plan and he had our troops
there
facili just standing around the airport
for for for days and days facilitating
the evacuation of thousands and
thousands of afghan civilians and
citizens
while our own people are trapped um and
so this is on him and you and you would
think if that really registered on him
then the last thing he'd be doing is
checking his watch
he maybe he'd be looking at his hands
and the blood on his hands
but not his watch so
no benefit of the doubt for joe biden at
all also no benefit of the doubt for dr
fauci who has now come out fully in
favor of vaccine mandates for children
this is another one of the many issues
that he's
he's flip-flopped on and he's taken one
side of it on the other side and back to
that side and back and back again and
now he's on the side of of mandating
vaccines for children in public school
especially
the reasons that he gives
for advocating this policy are as usual
extremely misleading listen
i want to ask you about some local
issues culver city unified school
district in california became the first
public school district in the u.s to
require
vaccinations not only for teachers and
staff but also for eligible students who
are 12 and over now that the vaccine has
full approval from the fda the the
pfizer vaccine would you like to see it
mandated for students elsewhere in the
u.s and once it's approved for kids
under 12 should it be mandated for them
too
you know i know that a lot of people
will be pushing back against that but if
you get the imprimatur about the safety
and the strong benefit risk ratio for
the children when that gets established
which i believe it certainly will
by the fda and the acip i believe that
mandating vaccines for children to
appear in school is a good idea and
remember jake this is not something new
we have mandates in many places in
schools particularly public schools that
if in fact you want a child to come in
we've done this for decades and decades
requiring polio measles mumps rubella
hepatitis so this would not be something
new
requiring vaccinations for children to
come to school
yeah it's not anything new but notice
what he the the examples he gives
measles
uh mumps
polio rubella
what what are those uh what are those
hepatitis aside what are those other
illnesses diseases
have in common
well they all especially impact and
affect children
covid does not
and and that's that's the point
okay covid does not
it's not just that it doesn't especially
affect children
it's that it very rarely has any severe
effect at all
and i've been beating this drum for
months and months now i've said this
over and over again we got to keep
saying it because it's true
that's that's not like in irrelevant
fact here
now dr fauci and the people in charge
they want us to think that this is
irrelevant the fact that kovid
is very very mild with kids we hear
about all of it it sounds very scary
when you hear about the the spike in
cases for kids and and all the millions
of kids who've gotten it i mean it was
supposedly 42 million
a month ago and probably more than that
i mean those are just the cases that we
know about um
and that sounds really scary but then
you realize that in the vast majority of
those cases this
it was they had the sniffles
you know they may had a mild fever they
had a little bit of cough maybe
or maybe less than that
and that's the point that's the
difference that's the difference between
covet 19 where kids are concerned and
like polio
and it's an important difference
and that factors in with vaccine
mandates or factors in with mass
mandates or it should anyway
but what they want us to do is they want
us to pretend
that everybody is equal in this regard
that everyone is is uh
we have to operate as though everybody
has a
a you know is in the severe risk is in a
high risk group
even when they're clearly not
that's how that's how they want the
policies to be written
which doesn't make any sense now it has
never made any sense at all
all right next this is from cwb in
chicago it says a liquor store security
guard was acting in self-defense when he
shot a customer three times because the
customer was putting other lives at risk
by not wearing a coveted mask
the guard's private defense attorney
said during a court a bond court hearing
on wednesday he was
you know defending this and saying well
he was a self-defense
um the argument did not sway cook county
judge mary marubio who said quote the
victim fled the store fell outside
followed by the defendant who according
to the surveillance video shot a second
time
the defendant then paces back and forth
and shot a third time
holmes who was barred from possessing a
weapon because he's a four-time
convicted felon and registered child sex
offender but was working as a security
guard apparently
was working as an armed security guard
at the store on the 6000 block
uh of south racine avenue when a 28 year
old man walked in without a covered mask
around 9 53 a.m
holmes and the victim argued about the
mass policy and the victim eventually
left
and then he turned around and walked
back in
and when he did holmes met him with a
drawn handgun and then shot him
um
and now the defense which fortunately is
not
playing out exactly but the defense is
that that he was operating in
self-defense because this guy was
basically a biological terrorist and
didn't have he didn't have a mask on
now we're gonna leave aside the fact
that this was an armed security guard
that got a job somehow
even though he was not legally able to
possess a firearm
and he was a convicted felon and child
sex offender
so that raises a lot of questions
but
putting that to the side
he he was this is someone who was taking
what he's told about kovid and masks
seriously
i mean if everything we're told about
masking is true
then actually we should let this guy out
of prison
i mean i heard very similar things when
i was at the uh the
uh
school board meeting
listening to pro mask they didn't have
guns they weren't shooting anybody thank
god
but they got up there in front of the
front of the microphone and they said
that hey if you let your
your child will murder my child if you
let him wear
go without a mask around my kid
bare-faced people are going to murder me
when you go out when your kid goes out
when you go out without a mask on you're
killing other people
i heard that at the school board meeting
we heard that at many school board
meetings that's why they put these mass
mandates in place
and we've all heard this from the mask
cult over and over and over again
you walk around without a master killing
you are directly killing people
and there's no evidence for that
whatsoever it's totally insane and
hysterical but that's the that's the
claim anyway
and if that's true i mean if not wearing
a mask is an is a murderous act
then it would seem to me that um
this security guard acted
reasonably
given that fact
which of course he really didn't act
reasonably at all but this this just
goes to show this rhetoric about masking
it has consequences
okay
like it it
it leads to things
this is not happening in a vacuum
this is the consequence when you go
around telling people
that if they see someone else simply
bearing their face in public walking
into a store briefly
without a mask on that they are a in an
immediate
dire potentially fatal risk to you well
this is the consequence
because there are a lot of insane people
out there and they listen to that and
they take it seriously now when you say
it you might not mean it seriously this
for you is all a game this is just
rhetoric for you
but there are a lot of people who
believe it
and uh
this this falls on you ultimately i
would say all right next year
mississippi uh governor tate reeves is
being criticized today for some comments
he made at a fundraiser
uh this is from salon it says tate
reeves told a tennessee audience
that southerners are a little less
scared of cover 19 due to their
religious faith
the mississippi free press report on
saturday the state has now recorded 8
279 fatalities but governor reeves does
not seem that worried
he said i'm often asked by some of my
friends on the other side of the aisle
about covid and why does it seem like
folks in mississippi and maybe in the
mid-south are a little less scared shall
we say
uh reeve said in a fundraiser
when you believe in eternal life when
you believe that living on this earth is
but a blip on the screen then you don't
have to be so scared of things you said
now god also tells us to take
precautions to take necessary
precautions
so
he's getting a lot of criticism for this
but
this of course is true and there's
nothing wrong with saying it
the point isn't that that if you believe
in eternal life
um that you should be reckless or
suicidal and not care about your
physical life in this in this life
it's just that if you believe
that this life is it
and that death is like a portal into a
black abyss into nothingness
and all of you will be erased forever
and ever
then that would naturally cause a
crippling incapacitating fear of death
so it's okay to be afraid of death you
don't want to die nobody wants to die if
you want to die than you're suicidal
but what we're seeing now what we've
seen with kovid it goes far beyond that
it's people who are clinging on to this
life so desperately
to the point of not accepting even even
the most reasonable risks not wanting to
walk outside their house without a mask
on that kind of thing you know
driving in a car by yourself with a mask
on jogging down the street with a mask
on that kind of thing
these are people who their fear of death
is crippling and incapacitating
it paralyzes them they can't function
because in order to function as just a
normal human in society you need to be
able to accept
the inevitability of death and the
possibility of death as you go about
your daily life
i think it's easier for people who
believe in eternal life and people who
believe in an afterlife to do that
if you don't believe in that then in a
way i can't really blame you because
what you're
what you believe is that after you die
your body will decay into the dirt and
you'll be eaten by worms
and
you will just be nothing
the black abyss of nothingness is a is a
it is hard to feel anything but but
crippling existential dread when you
think about that if that's what you
believe
so i think it's a reasonable point it's
an important point that he raises there
but of course
reasonable kind of nuanced important
philosophical points are not things that
that you can make these days
without uh people crying about it and
next a couple of hollywood news items
here um
because the networks haven't had an
original idea in about three decades abc
is now coming out with a reboot of the
wonder years
the original a classic
came out in the 80s was set in the 60s
so it was nostalgic for most of the
audience that watched it at the time you
know they were like thinking about uh
when they grew up in the 60s so if
you're gonna do a reboot you would think
that um which you shouldn't but if you
are you'd think that it'd be set in the
90s so that it's nostalgic for the
audiences that will watch it now
but because hollywood can't even execute
its own rehashed ideas correctly this
one is also set in the 60s
so it's the same exact time frame as the
original but this this time with a black
cast
so keep the same time
swap out the races this of course
destroys the whole point of the show as
most of the people who watch it aren't
going to be people who grew up in the
60s they're going to be people who grew
up in the 80s and the 90s
um
well the people who watch it won't have
grown up at any time in per in history
because
nobody will watch it those people don't
exist but if anyone did watch it
um
it's going to be people who grew up in
the 80s and 90s
so why would they do this
why would they do a reboot in the same
time period at the 60s but just
switch the races what's the point of
doing that
well let's check out the trailer maybe
we can find out let's watch this
it's weird to grow up in a time when
your mom and dad have to give you the
police talk or when a presidential
election creates a racial divide but it
was 1968
the year i turned 12
the age of locker rooms
bullies hey
four eyes
girls my mom is making me wear pantyhose
yuck
yeah
some people didn't feel like we needed
to mix black people with white people
i didn't understand all that what's
happening chad how's it going quentin
black jesus you're trying too hard
but i decided what my bag would be
the great uniter
think about how possibly to have our
teams played each other why would you
want to play with a bunch of white boys
why does that matter how do you know if
you don't try isn't that what you're
always telling me
okay so that so that's why of course
they they want the whole point to be
that white people are evil and uh that's
a lot easier to do if you said it in the
60s so that's that's what
that's really what it all comes down to
and that's why i know no one's going to
watch that show but they just can't help
themselves
they must know at some level there's not
going to be any audience for that
but they can't help themselves they
can't they just they just can't speaking
of not being able to help themselves
there's a more hollywood news here
there's this new cinderella movie coming
out awoke cinderella uh woker than the
last one which i assume was also woke
but uh the fairy godmothers played by a
dude in a dress
that's the main thing that's the main
the main thing that makes it woke anyway
apparently nobody cares about this movie
or wants to see it so the producers had
a great idea um and uh and so what they
decided was let's have the stars of the
film
go out into the street
and stop traffic
and thrust their pelvises into the faces
of
irritated motorists it's an unorthodox
plan
i don't know if it paid off but uh
here's the footage of james corden in a
mouse costume and the fairy godmother
dude and someone else all dancing in the
street let's uh let's check that out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now i want you to imagine something
imagine that you're running
late to a job you hate
uh maybe you just got word that there's
i don't know mold in your basement and
it'll cost four thousand dollars to rip
the drywall out and get rid of it and
then on your way to work
you know you stop at starbucks and they
get your order wrong
um
but the line is too long to go back
around and now you're late to your
crappy job you're sitting in traffic and
you're wondering what the hell is
causing the hold up and then out of
nowhere
james corden comes running up with a
with a
with a jlo song playing and starts
jiggling his genitals in your face
in a mouse costume
i mean that's the last straw right there
that's when you go full michael douglas
and falling down you know
that's when you experience a a sudden
and mysterious problem with your
breaking system i think
and yeah you just plow through those
lunatics and
some would say
some would say i do not say this i don't
say this but some would say
you would make the world a better place
in the process
if you were to keep just driving through
those people i
shame on the people who say that because
i don't say it but
shame on them
all right um
moving on now to reading the youtube
comments
uh this is from mind traveler says
one could make it's reigning them a
hundred times better
by imagining it's about the giant
man-eating ants from the 1954 movie them
uh yeah i mean that's that's one way you
could improve it it's raining them as we
played during the daily cancellation on
friday another way to improve it is just
for it to not exist at all
i think probably is the way to go
uh bk lee says matt the member of the
weather girls is martha wash not walsh
she's an outstanding singer i did get
that one wrong i identified
uh that is so that's a fact check
very rarely do i let anybody in the
comment section or or in general fact
check me but here this is one fact check
and i admit you are correct i did
identify the lead singer of the weather
girls as martha walsh and i was very
excited thinking maybe this is someone
who's related to me somehow
although it seemed unlikely given you
know the racial differences uh but
apparently it's wash not walsh so i
jumped the gun on that one
uh tipdia says if matt experiences hot
privilege then blindness is an epidemic
how dare you
but good one and also your band from the
show colton says matt to be fair you
have to think about the hundreds of
people trying to enter the capital that
day while one unarmed woman might not
seem very threatening the mob that she
was included in was
i'm not saying bird is in the right but
he definitely has a case for himself and
his non-apology was very matt
walsh-esque
oh yeah i've heard this argument
uh many times in
you know defending the officer who shot
ashley babbitt
but that goes back to the question that
i raised on on friday which is if that's
the case then why didn't any other
capitol police officer fire his weapon
that day you know
why was he the only one who did it
if if if this was necessary there were
mobs of people all over the capitol if
it was necessary to fire a gun to stop
them
and they had to do this to like what
disperse the crowd is that is that the
idea
so it wasn't even that she individually
posed a threat
but that um
but that they had to do this to disperse
the crowd
i mean it's not just that no one else in
the at the capitol did that
it's that from all of the riots that
we've seen across the country
um
that never happened anywhere
so officer byrd was was the only officer
at the capitol that day who felt that he
had to kill someone to disperse the
crowd if and and he's also the only
officer involved in any riots across the
country anywhere
this entire time who's who felt that he
had to do that to take that step
and the person that he felt he had to
kill was ashley babbitt an unarmed five
foot two five foot two inch woman
who was climbing through a window at the
time
and you think he could have easily just
grabbed her and pulled her down
you know she was in a very vulnerable
spot right there she didn't have her
hands she was she was pulling her throat
and so so was was there were there were
there no other
uh
options
aside from the from the fatal option
i find that very hard to believe
um another comment says matt actually
the case against lieutenant bird is even
stronger than you describe you claim
that he said that he doesn't know
whether ashley babbitt was armed uh he
admits something worse he said that
knowing whether ashley babbitt was armed
or not wouldn't have made a difference
to its decision to shoot her
how is he not being prosecuted well yeah
that's the point that i also made i i
don't think i i don't think i phrased it
as you said that i phrase it that's how
the media is phrasing it where officer
bird said that he didn't know if she was
armed
um
that would be one thing okay if you had
said that it'd be one thing if you said
you know i thought she was armed but i
didn't know or or no no rather
the way the media is phrasing it is
he didn't know that she wasn't armed
okay
but in reality what he said was
that
whether or not she was armed was
irrelevant
that's what he actually said
which is just an incredible statement
that no other officer would ever be able
to get away with ever
what did you think that the suspect was
armed before you shot them well but
didn't make it did make a difference
really it didn't
no other officer would be able to get
away with that not even close
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so bringing the show around full circle
there's been a newly intense focus on
mental health in this country over the
past few months especially more
specifically in the sports world as we
all certainly remember simone biles
became a champion for mental health
when she courageously quit on her team
in the middle of the olympics and then
even more courageously cured her own
mental health
problems just in time to you know
compete for an individual medal before
biles naomi osaka as a tennis star paved
the way by dropping out of the french
open because she was afraid to take
questions from the media she said that
taking questions might damage her mental
health and then a few months later when
she started taking questions again this
was a few weeks ago a reporter promptly
reduced her to tears and was condemned
as a bully by her agent
because he very gently asked a couple of
really fair and banal questions
that reporter deserved the reaction that
he got though he should have known
better than to ask questions at a press
conference the job of the press at a
press conference
as the white house press corps could
certainly tell you
is to take terms complimenting the
person behind the microphone
unless that person is a confirmed or
suspected republican of course in which
case it's a totally different deal your
job then is to destroy them so it's kind
of a there's a nuance there
the overwhelming emotional fragility of
our nation's athletes has led to some
important changes though for example the
u.s open will now have quiet rooms for
athletes to retreat to to get in touch
with their emotions and maybe have a
good cry
and that actually kind of reminds me of
an idea that i've had
should i ever run my own business
my plan is to have special cry rooms
where anyone in the company can go and
cry and get in touch with their emotions
and uh you know there will be a mirror
there so they can stare at themselves
and repeat their self-help mantras and
affirmations but the mirror will be
double-sided and people on the other
side can gather and laugh at the
weakling
and then the sprinklers will turn on
inside the cry room and the sobbing
weirdo will emerge
humiliated at which point they'll be
fired in front of the whole office
i'll only be able to do this like once
before i'm sued into bankruptcy and
probably arrested but it'll be totally
worth it needless to say
anyway
the us open has a very different
approach and naomi osaka itself
certainly has a different approach to to
mental health just yesterday she
published a lengthy note on social media
talking about her mental health journey
and and what she's learned
she's being widely hailed for these
reflections it's being called brave and
wise and everyone says it's a very
wonderful thing and very you know very
affecting what she wrote here's what she
said she says recently i've been asked
asking myself why do i feel the way i do
and i realize one of the reasons is
because internally i think i'm never
good enough i never tell myself that
i've done a good job but i do know i
constantly tell myself that i suck or i
could do better
i know in the past some people have
called me humble but if i really
consider it i think i'm extremely
self-deprecating every time a new
opportunity arises my first thought is
wow why me i guess what i'm trying to
say is that i'm going to try to
celebrate myself and my accomplishments
more i think we all should you get up in
the morning and didn't procrastinate on
something champion figured something out
at work that's been bugging you for a
while absolute legend your life is your
own and you shouldn't value yourself on
other people's standards
i know i give my heart to everything i
can
and if that's not good enough for some
then my apologies but i can't burden
myself with those expectations anymore
so that's what she wrote now this advice
is pretty standard
uh it's not all wrong by any means to
begin with she correctly identifies
which is important the distinction
between being humble and being
self-loathing a person who's
self-loathing may appear humble but
humility
is when you recognize
your gifts and your talents and your
positive qualities and you don't you
don't dwell on them or expect anyone
else to dwell on them
if you don't recognize those good things
about yourself at all or you deny them
or you're overcome by doubt about them
then there can't be humility because
there's no opportunity for you for
humility because you aren't even
acknowledging the existence of the
things that you should be humble about
so she's correct about that she's also
correct of course that you shouldn't be
overly focused on living up to the
public's expectations of
you mainly because the expectations of
the masses of the mob
will differ wildly from person to person
and uh many of the people in that mob
really have no reason or right to expect
anything from you at all but does that
mean that you should ignore everyone's
expectations does that mean that you
shouldn't try to live up to anyone's
standards but your own
no absolutely not
there are people in your life who in
various contexts
should have certain expectations where
you're concerned certain standards that
they want you to live up to and you
absolutely should care about that and
you should try your best to get over
those bars where they've been set so at
a very basic level
i know that my family expects that i'll
be a protector and provider for them my
wife expects that i'll be faithful and
loyal live up to my vows my employer
expects that i'll do the job that they
hired me to do
in my job also there are even
expectations from the public or some
people in the public that i do feel
bound to live up to i think the audience
expects that i'll be honest about my
opinions and straightforward i won't
pull my punches and so on so with every
title
that i hold father husband
even podcast host not to mention an
american most importantly christian
there are expectations that come as a
part of the bargain responsibilities
that i have to something
bigger than myself and that's the case
for everyone in every area of your life
big areas and small areas if you're an
olympic athlete
it's expected that you'll go out there
and do your best for your country
compete to the best of your ability
these are expectations and standards
that we should try to live up to and if
we don't live up to them or even try
then we're rightly labeled failures
failure is always judged against
expectations which is why people want to
get rid of expectation so they can get
rid of failure
but it doesn't work that way
one other point i've made this point
many times but i think it's worth
repeating osaka says
i'm going to try to celebrate myself and
my accomplishments more you know she
says if you get up in the morning and
you don't procrastinate then you're a
champion if you figure out something at
work you know you do your job then
you're you're a legend that's that's
what she says
but none of this is the solution to the
problem that osaka apparently has it's
not the solution to the problem that
lots of us have her problem again shared
by many shared by everyone to some
degree
is one of self-doubt and anxiety and
self-loathing
you can't you go you're you can't you go
girl yourself out of that state you
can't convince yourself to stop hating
yourself by pretending that functioning
as a responsible adult is some kind of
major achievement
you can celebrate yourself all you want
you can pop the champagne drop the
confetti every time you complete an
assignment on time or brush your teeth
in the morning or tie your shoes
but nobody will be convinced by those
theatrics
least of all yourself
the answer is not to think of yourself
differently but to think of yourself
less
osaka seems to you know be up in her own
head constantly thinking about herself
how she feels about herself how other
people feel about how she feels about
herself
it's like getting stuck in this
self-obsessed vortex the same vortex
that most people in our society cannot
seem to escape from they're always
looking within trying to convince
themselves to feel differently about
what they see and they may have
intermittent intermittent success with
that moments where they can say you know
what i feel great about myself
and actually believe what they're saying
about themselves
but those moments are fleeting
because they always eventually fall back
into the vortex back into the cycle of
self-hate and self-doubt
here's an alternative suggestion
don't worry about how you feel about
yourself
stop thinking about it
think about something else anything else
i don't even pick up your phone and try
to take your mind off it because your
phone will always just direct you back
into your own ego i mean look outward
actually outward
go play with your kids or read a book
about a random subject or go for a run
or learn how to whittle or something or
pray not about your own problems but
about someone else's
or pick up beekeeping that's a good one
i mean do anything but focus on your own
feelings about yourself try to spend
most of your day doing things other than
that turn your eyes back around facing
the direction they're supposed to face
extend your thoughts out in the
direction of something other than your
own reflection
just forget yourself for as long as you
can
it takes practice but you learn and
that's the key
and that's the way for all of us
including naomi osaka
though still
because this is the segment
even though i'm trying to help her in
the end i have to still say to her
that she is today canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day everybody godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright dailywire
2021.
today on the ben shapiro show the biden
administration finally admits we'll be
leaving hundreds if not thousands of
americans and green card holders behind
in afghanistan according to the white
house it's time to rely on the taliban
and joe biden can't be bothered to
answer questions about any of it that's
today on the bench shapiro show give it
a listen